ja und gerade bei uns für die kamera
gerannt ganz knapp hat geklappt ist
alles weide die fraktionsvorsitzende der
afd frau beide wir haben eine umfrage
vorher gespielt falls sie es nicht
gehört haben da haben die leute auf der
straße sicher nicht repräsentativ aber
einige gesagt dass sie offenbar vor
allem soziale sorgen haben was ist ihr
konzept was ist das konzept der afg
dagegen beispiel altersarmut beispiel
pflege also altersarmut und pflege dazu
haben wir folgendes konzipiert für den
anfang vor allen dingen in unserem
arbeitskreis aber auch in dem
dazugehörigen im ausschuss also es muss
grundsätzlich gelten dass menschen die
jahrzehntelang in die sozialversicherung
eingezahlt haben später ein gutes leben
haben wenn sie in rente gehen das ist
ein grundsatz der eingehalten werden
muss das ist das erste
das zweite ist bei einem
sozialversicherungssystem beispielsweise
bei der arbeitslosenversicherung kann es
nicht sein wenn sie beispielsweise 30
jahre eingezahlt haben dann arbeitslos
werden dass sie dann nur ein jahr ein
anrecht auf bezüge haben und danach auf
hartz iv niveau absinken das kann nicht
sein
da sagen wir eben auch da muss das
sozialversicherungs technische
äquivalenzprinzip auch eingehalten
werden das sich eben auch die auszahlung
zeit in der arbeitslosenkasse eben an
die einzahlung zeit mit knüpft und wir
sagen auch ganz klar es kann letztlich
nicht sein dass menschen sozial bezüge
aus unseren sozialsystemen beziehen die
dort nie eingezahlt haben und teilweise
auch sich illegal in unserem land
aufhalten
und da sehen wir beispielsweise bei der
großen koalition überhaupt gar keine
lösung für den unbegrenzten zuzug
teilweise auch unberechtigten zuzug von
illegalen zuwanderern in unsere
sozialsysteme
das kann niemand mehr finanzieren und
die leute auf der strasse verstehen das
einfach nicht
und wenn ich noch zum abschluss etwas
sagen darf ich bin schockiert dass
rentner in unserem land flaschen sammeln
müssen
das kann so nicht sein das ist auch
einem industrieland überhaupt nicht
würdig was die höchste steuer und
abgabenlast eben von westlichen
industrieländern hat das kann so nicht
sein dass menschen auf tafeln angewiesen
sind und flaschen sammeln müssen während
andere sich mit ihren zweit und dritt
frauen in deutschland niederlassen
syrische flüchtlinge und dann irgendwie
nicht arbeiten gehen können weil sie die
sprache nicht beherrschen und sieben bis
zehn kinder durch füttern wollen wie in
dem fall ahmad gesehen das ist natürlich
ein schwieriger vergleich die
regierungserklärung heute wo werden sie
dann noch ganz besonders hinhören
wir werden vor allen dingen hören was
die kanzlerin oder auch horst seehofer
nachher zur inneren sicherheit zu sagen
haben also das wird recht interessant
denn es wird ihr allgemeinhin überhaupt
gar nicht darüber gesprochen dass die
kriminalitätsrate im zuge der
zuwanderung dramatisch angestiegen ist
wir können anhand vom bka statistiken
eben feststellen dass in bezug auf
rohheitsdelikte gewalttaten in die
bilanz so zu deuten ist dass
asylbewerber 16-fach so kriminell sind
wie eben deutsche staatsbürger und das
ist ein problem das wir endlich
ansprechen müssen darauf werden wir auch
heute antworten herr seehofer kommt
ihnen der insofern entgegen als dass er
die grenzkontrollen verschärfen will das
hat er angekündigt oder zumindest
beibehalten teilweise auch verschärfen
will
das sind ja positionen mit denen können
sie sich ja dann auch anfreunden
sie haben es gerade ganz richtig gesagt
herr seehofer hat ja nur angekündigt das
macht er schon seit jahren der könig nur
an und setzte nicht um
und wenn wir uns die abstimmung letzte
woche anschauen dass man unseren antrag
abgelehnt hatte auf grenzkontrollen und
grenzsicherung aber wirklich alle
parteien durchweg dann wissen wir doch
wie es mit dem versprechen von
grenzkontrollen und grenzsicherung
er ist also das sind alles so neben
kerzen und es wird letztendlich nicht
umgesetzt mit welchem begründung haben
die anderen parteien ihr vorhaben denn
abgelehnt in der sache ist es so sie
haben es abgelehnt und da müssen sie
einfach mal die anderen parteien fragen
warum sie eigentlich nicht dafür sind
dass man die eigene bevölkerung schützt
denn das ist originäre staatsaufgabe die
grenzen zu sichern und zu kontrollieren
und auch festzustellen wer sich
innerhalb unserer staatsgrenzen aufhält
hier hat der staat komplett die
kontrolle aufgegeben da müssen sie
einfach mal die konkurrenzparteien
fragen warum sie dagegen votiert haben
dass der staat eigentlich im stande ist
überhaupt primär seine bevölkerung zu
schützen
es hat eine internetumfrage der afg
berlin gegeben auch zum thema seehofer
da wurde die hat die afg berlin gefragt
gehört der islam zu deutschland da haben
83 prozent der dort teil der teilnehmer
dort gesagt ja der islam gehört zu
deutschland daraufhin wurde dieser tweet
gelöscht müssen sie nicht als afd auch
solche umfragen die natürlich nicht
repräsentativ aber müssen sie das nicht
trotzdem aushalten dass man so was
immerhin mal sieht auf den twitter
account immer also sowas muss man
aushalten also das ist ja die afg berlin
gewesen wenn man so eine umfrage
schaltet dann muss man sich die frage
stellen wer daran teilnimmt
sie haben es ja schon gesagt sie haben
einen kleinen ausschnitt und dann sollte
man das auch nachher diskutieren also
ich weiß nicht ob es jetzt gelöscht
wurde oder nicht aber das sollte man
auch einfach stehen lassen und an
diskutieren sie haben sich ja den
koalitionsvertrag gelesen gibt es da
irgendwas wo sie jetzt sagen dass es
positiv dass geht in die richtung die
wir auch haben oder sagen sie
fundamental sie lehnen das ganze werk ab
das problem an dem koalitionsvertrag ist
dass er noch weiter nach links gerückt
ist das ist ein komplett durch und durch
sozialdemokratisierte koalitionsvertrag
der überhaupt gar keine antworten gibt
auf die dringenden probleme in unserem
land also wenn wir uns beispielsweise
auch
ressorts angucken wie der energiepolitik
die energiewende belastet private
haushalte aber auch den mittelstand
kleinen handwerksbetriebe
überproportional hoch so dass sie nicht
mehr wettbewerbsfähig sind und private
haushalte wirklich darunter leiden dass
die energiekosten von jahr zu jahr
steigen
auch darauf kriegen wir keine antwort
und dann in den letzten jahren wurde uns
immer wieder versprochen dass die bürger
entlastet werden die arbeiten lebende
bevölkerung nichts davon ist der fall
ganz im gegenteil haben man will immer
mehr ausgeben
der haushalt wurde auch noch vergrößern
wird immer mehr auch an brüssel
umverteilen
obwohl großbritannien austritt und der
haushalt eigentlich kleiner werden
müsste und auch hier sehen wir keine
entlastung beispielsweise für den
mittelstand ich habe am anfang schon
ausgeführt deutschland hat die größte
die höchste steuer und abgabenquote von
den westlichen industrieländern und da
ist auch überhaupt gar nichts in sicht
dass man die arbeitnehmer und bürger
endlich mal entlastet indem man die
einkommensteuer senkt die afg hat dazu
vorschläge gemacht wir sind für einen
vereinfachten stufentarif im
einkommensteuerrecht wir sind für die
abschaffung der kalten progression
endlich mal und wir sind für ein
familiensplitting modell das vor allen
dingen familien entlastet werden
steuerlich und daneben noch zuzüglich
die mehrwertsteuer auch abzusenken und
den sony endlich abzuschaffen
alice will war dass die
fraktionsvorsitzende der afg zur
anstehenden regierungserklärung vielen
dank